قال مراسل الجزيره ان مباحثات مباشره بين
ممثلين عن الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع انطلقت الظهر السبت في مدينه جده
بالتزامن مع استمرار الاشتباكات بين
الجانبين في الخرطوم وكان بيان امريكي
سعودي قد رحب بما سماها محادثات ما قبل
التفاوض في جده بينما اكد الجيش السوداني
ان مشاركته في المباحثات ستقتصر على
الجوانب العسكريه والانسانيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاسه ثلاثه مسارات ما الذي يمكن ان تحققه
مباحثات جده وما الذي يعنيه اصرار الجيش
على بحث قضايا عسكريه وانسانيه وتاكيد
رفضه مناقشه مسار التسويه كيف يمكن ان
تنعكس جهود التفاوض هذه على الاشتباكات
الجاريه على الارض وما فرص نجاحها في ضوء
تواصل المعارك حول مقر الحكم الرئيسيه
وما دلاله الاعلان عن هذه المباحثات عقب
تهديد الامريكي بفرض عقوبات على شخصيات
سودانيه وكيف سينعكس هذا الموقف على دور
واشنطن في السودان
[موسيقى]
بوفدين يضم كل منهما سبعه افراد قال مراسل
الجزيره ان المباحثات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع انطلقت ظهر السبت في
مدينه جده برعايه وزاره الخارجيه الصعوديه
وفي اطار المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه لحل
النزاع في السودان وزير الخارجيات
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان ال سعود
اعرب عن امله في ان يقود حوار جده الى
انهاء الصراع بين الطرفين وانطلاق العمليه
السياسيه وعوده الامن والاستقرار الى
السودان واضاف الوزير السعودي ان استضافه
المباحثات السودانيه نتاج تكاتف دوري او
جهود حديثه مع الولايات المتحده بالشراكه
مع دول المجموعه الرباعيه والاليه
الثلاثيه
الجيش السوداني الذي قال مصدر منه للجزيره
ان قبول التفاوض ياتي استجابه للمبادره
الامريكيه السعوديه وان التفاوض سيكون في
القضايا العسكريه والانسانيه فقط اكد
المتحدث باسمه باسم الجيش للجزيره ان
محادثات الجده لا علاقه لها باي اتفاقا
نهائيا لوقف اطلاق النار او انهاء الى
ازمه في البلاد
نحن اعلنا عند انطلاق وفدنا او مغادره
وفدنا الى جده ان هذا الوقت ذهب
وسيناقش الجوارب التي تتعلق بالغذنه بما
يتم تنفيذها لتحقيق او لخدمه الاغراض
الانسانيه بالمقام الاول لانه نحن الان
هذه حرب او هذه معركه دور في مدينه مدينه
الخرطوم عاصمه البلاد بها عدد كبير من
سكان هم تؤثرون تماما بما يجري احداث على
الارض
اما قوات الدعم السريع فقد رحب قائدها
محمد حمدان حماتي بالبيان السعودي
الامريكي المشترك الذي صدر بشان بدء
محادثات جده وشدد احمد في تغريده على
تويتر على ما سماه موقفه الثابت بضروره
الوصول الى حكومه انتقاليه مدنيه تؤسس
لتحولا ديمقراطي واشاد بالجهود الاقليميه
والدوليه المبذوله للوصول الى وقف اطلاق
نار يسهل فتح ممرات انسانيه
[موسيقى]
لمناقصه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
الخرطوم الفريق اول فتح الرحمن محي الدين
قائد قوات البحريه السودانيه سابقا ومن
الخرطوم ايضا حافظ كبير الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ومن واشنطن
السفير الامريكيه السابق في السودان ابدا
معك الفريق اول فتح الرحمن محي الدين
عندما يقول المتحدث باسم الجيش ان محادثات
جدا ستقتصر على التفاوض في القضايا
العسكريه والانسانيه فقط فصل لنا في هاتين
النقطتين ما هي القضايا العسكريه
والانسانيه
المشاهدين
تم التواصل عليها ولكنها كلها لم تخدم
تحسن الوضع لان الانسان
وبالتالي يعني كان لابد من البحث في سبيل
ايجاد فرص لنجاح الهدنه لكي يستفيد منها
المواطن في تحسين حياته يعني لا يمكن ان
نتحدث عن هدنه وعناصر التمرد تحتل محطات
الكهرباء تحتل محطات المياه تحتل
المستشفيات وتحويلها الى عسكريه تحتل
منازل المواطنين وتتخذهم بروح بشريه في كل
هذه الاوضاع يعني لا يمكن الاوضاع
الانسانيه ان تتحسن تحت ظن الهدنه
وبالتالي يعني هذا هذه المفاوضات الغرض
الاساسي منها هو ضروره اخراج عناصر التمرد
من وسط الاحياء السكانيه من المستشفيات من
محطات الكهرباء من محطات المياه
حتى ينعم المواطن بخدمات الكهرباء وخدمات
المياه والعلاج وحريه تتحركه والتنقل دون
عوائق
قوات المسلحه قسما سلامه العناصر عندما
تخرج من هذه الاماكن
وتوافقوا على مكان معين تتجمع فيه هذه
القوات وتضمن سلامته الرواتب وبعد ذلك لكن
في هذه المرحله الغرض من الاساسي
الاختلاف الكبير
حركه التمرج
اسمع تعليق من السيد حافظ كبير سيد حافظ
يعني هل يمكن ان توافق قوات الدعم السريع
على هذا المقترح تخرج من المناطق الحيويه
او المناطق الاساسيه التي يحتاج اليها
السكان وتتجمع في جزء معين بحمايه او يضمن
الجيش سلامه افرادها في هذه الحاله
تحيه طيبه لكم الكرام والمشاهدين انا
اعتقد ان هذا الامر اهداف التفاوض التي
اعلن عنها الجيش لا تتفق مع اي عمليه
تصاعديه هذه الاهداف التي ذكرها لا تستحق
يعني التفاوض في جده
الوقود التي
ذهبت هي يعني هن كان يمكن اتفاق عليها عبر
وساطات دوليه لكن اعتقد ان الهدف الاساسي
من التفاوض هو الوصول الى اتفاق النهائي
الاكتشاف الذي يعني نشهده الاخوان الدعم
الفري في الاحياء او في الاماكن المختلفه
ولم يكن بحد ذاته سببا وانما
والنقاش ينبغي ان يركز على الاسباب
الاساسيه للصراع المسلح وليس حياه
الصراع هذه الاسباب واذا لم تعد الاسباب
المرجوه كله حتى الانسانيه
ولم تنفذ اذا ظلت
فان عدم الثقه الذي يخيم الان على المشهد
يسعف الاطراف في التنفيذ اي برنامج اخر
جزئي وبالتالي
الاساسي لوقف اطلاق النار وللعمليه
للمساعده الانسانيه هو اتفاق شامل
وبضمانات معلومه
وفي ظل هذه الاجواء التي اشرت اليها لا
يثق الدعم السريع في اي حديث يقوله الجيش
خاصه انه يتبنى الهدنه ثم يتراجع عنها ثم
كذلك يقول انه لا يريد التفاوض ثم يقول
مره اخرى انه يتفاوض هناك تاريخ طويل من
عدم الوفاء بالعود وبالتالي
لا تجد ان هذه المره يتفاوض التراث
يتفاوضون على الجوانب الانسانيه بيعزل عن
الاسباب التي قادت الى هذه الظروف
الانسانيه طيب اسمع من السيد تيمو سيد
تيموسي كورني من الواضح ان كل طرف لديه
رؤيه مختلفه لهذه
المحادثات ماذا عن رؤيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لهذه المحادثات وهي التي ساعدت
مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه لاجراءها
اعتقد انه علينا ان ندرك بانه ثمه مرحله
على الاقل وان هذه عمليه جاريه نعم في
نهايه المطاف
السيد حافظ كبير محق بقوله انه لابد هناك
حل حلا شاملا ولكن هذا ليس هو الغرض كما
فهمته من هذه المحادثات هذه المحادثات كما
قال حميدتي نفسه
تركز على خلق ممرات انسانيه
للتعامل مع الاحتياجات الانسانيه للشعب
السوداني
وهذا حسب رايي هو سبب
علقا من حيث البدايه في جده سيلتقون في
جده الان
الدبلوماسيون وصفوا هذا على ان حينما
مرحله محادثات مرحله ما المفاوضات هذه لن
تكون مفاوضات الجوانب العسكريه او
السياسيه للنزاع
كما انني فهمته بان الجنرال فتح الله وسيد
حافظ كبير يريدان ان يتحدث او اسباب
الاساسيه اللي ادت الى النزاع لكن هذا امر
اخر يجب ان يناقش عنده مائده محادثات بين
الجانبين
لكن في وقت اخر طيب سيتم
يعني هل اعدنا الى
الهدن او وقف اطلاق نار مؤقت بغرض انساني
وهنالك اكثر من سبعه هدى الى حد الان
بالحقيقه سبعه هدى يوافق عليها كل جانب
ماذا عن محدد لماذا المحادثات المباشره
كان ممكن ان يتحقق ذلك عبر الوسطاء
نقطه هنا هيا ان الجانبين يجلسان سويه
ويتبادلان الحديد سويه بدلا ان يتحدثا عن
طريق وسائل الاعلام وهذا بذاته يعتبر تطور
مهم جدا في الموقف ولا اعرف ماذا سيكون
دور الولايات المتحده والسعوديه في في
اثناء المحادثات ذاتها حسب علمي لمحص على
اي نتائج للجلسه الاولى محاد ينبغي ان انا
كنت بدات في
ظهر اليوم بتوقيتكم في في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه علينا ان ننتظر ذلك
ولنرى ماذا ستكون خطوات التاليه في نهايه
المطاف اعتقد
واتوقع او امل بان هذه المحادثه ستؤدي الى
مناقشه فعليه لتحويل الهدنه الى وقف اطلاق
نار
وقف اطلاق النار امر صعب او معقد في
التفاوض اعود اليك فريق اول فتح الرحمن
محي الدين السيد تيموثي اشار الى نقطه
التفاوض
المباشر الجيش السوداني كان يرفض التفاوض
بشكل مباشر مع قوات الدعم السريع هل اليوم
ما جرى يدلل على مرونه معينه من قبل الجيش
على تطور في موقف الجيش فيما يتعلق
بالمحادثات مع الدعم السريع
لا يمكن ان يكون هنالك تفاوض مباشر هل
التفاوض يتيم عبر المساهلين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه ولا هم الذين يسهلوا الحوار ما
بين الوفد الحكومي السوداني ووفد التمرد
فهذا
التفاوض غير المباشر كما ذكرت لك الغرض
منه فقط تحصيل الاوض
اع في ظل الهدنه الاوضاع الانسانيه يعني
سبعه وثمانيه هدى للمدن
في المناطق الصراعات داخل الخرطوم لم
يستفيد منها الامن التمرد يخفى عليه
الطرقات يحتل منازله يحتل محطات الكهرباء
يحتلنا محطات المياه
طيب فريق اول فتح الرحمن محي الدين
لكي نستفيد من الوقت اذا كان الامر كذلك
اذا لماذا الذهاب الى جده اذا كان التفاوض
بشكل مباشر مرفوض واذا كان التفاوض محدد
بقضايا انسانيه لماذا الذهاب الى جده
للقيام بذلك الم يكن من الممكن ان يكون
يقوم الوسطاء بذلك كما يفعلون عبر نقل
الاخبار من جانب الى اخر او الاراء
يعني من الصعب يعني يكون بالتفاوض اما ان
يكون التفاوض بهذه الطريقه
بالقتال ويخراجهم بالقوه واخراج باستخدام
القوه داخل المستشفيات يعني استخدام
الغبيه للتدمير هذه المرابغ القدميه
تدميرا كامله وهل
لا ترضي وتريد ان تعيد الخدمه الى المواطن
باسرع مهم يمكن سواء كانت كهرباء ومئه
وبالتالي يجب ان يتم التفاوض مع العناصر
التي الاماكن لكي تخرج منها وحتى لا يكون
هنالك رساله ما ذكرت لك داخل المستشار
وحتى لا يكون مثال صلاحيات سكنيه ويعرض
كثير الى الابرياء الى الى الضرر والى
الموت يعني وتكون الخسائر البشريه كبيره
جدا وبالتالي تخرج هذه العناصر خلال
التصاد وبالادوات المسلحه
تنهي هذا النزاع في هذا
يبدون
ذلك عندما تخرج الاماكن
سؤال سريع في هذا الاطار
شهر مروه هذه القوات لم تخرج حسب ما تقول
على ماذا تبنون عندما تقولون بانه اذا لم
تخرج بالتفاوض ستخرج عن طريق
حل العسكري او عن بالطرق العسكريه على
ماذا تبنون هذه التوقعات
انا اعتقد انه لغات المسلحه لديها كثير من
الواقع الخاصه من
العناصر مكافحه الارهاب وعناصر تحرير
الرعايه يعني يعني قوات متخصصه في تحرير
يتم استخدامها حتى الان واستخدامها يتطلب
كثير جدا من الصبح استخدامه يتطلب زمن
اطول وان كانت هذه المفاوضات لم تاتي كلها
بالتاكيد القوات المسلحه الى القياده
الاخر الى
هذه المرافق خلال سياسه النفس الطويل
باستخدام رجل الخاصه دون احداث خسائر
كبيره وبالتالي تكون اخرجت ايضا
اصل هذا بالتاكيد من معاناه المواطن الذي
ينتظر ان تعود له خدمه الكهرباء والمياه
اليوم قبل الغد هذه كلها هذه المواضيع
ولكن يبدا لا مصر من دفع هذه الفاتوره اذا
لم
اسمع من السيد حافظه كبير سيد حافظ كبير
اذا لا يزال في جعبه الجيش الكثير من
الخيارات على المستوى العسكري قد يلجا
اليها السيد تيموثي يتحدث عن محادثات على
عده مراحل هل يمكن ان يرضي ذلك الدعم
السريع
محادثات يمكن تقييمها الى مراحل هذا مفهوم
لان الهدف ايضا من المحادثات الوصول الى
حكم مدني ديمقراطي في الاخر هذا مفهوم لكن
ان تقول بانك لا تتفاوض فقط تتفاوض في
القضايا الانسانيه والتركيبات هذا غير
مقبول لان الدعم لن يدخل في هذه لم يدافع
ويقاتل من اجل ثانيه هذه هي يعني يعني
النزاع وليست
اذا كنت تريد التفاوض عليك مناقشه اسباب
التفاؤل اسباب النزاع وليس يعني مترتبات
وليس اثاره وهذا يمكن يكون ذلك في مرحله
مقبله والمرحله الاولى تكون على هدنه
انسانيه
وبالتالي الان بمزيد من الضغوط والجهود
الدوليه الهدف الاساسي ما يزال مطروح امام
الاطراف ابويا واضحه بالنسبه للدعم السريع
وبالنسبه كلها السياسيه والقضيه الدعم
السريعه وحده هي قضيه
المجتمع السياسي الذي هو شريك العمليه
السيئات وبالتالي هناك الترتيبات عسكريه
هذه يتناقش حولها عسكريون وهناك ترتيبات
سياسيه القوات المسلحه اعلنت في بيانه
انها ملتزمه بالعمليه السياسيه وانها كذلك
ملتزمه بالمسار
المدني اذا كان ذلك
اليوم بعد شهر من
المواجهات بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
ايضا قوات الدعم السريعه لم تستطع ان تحقق
نصرا واضحا حاسما بالتالي ايضا هي ما
الخيارات التي تبقى امامها
العمل المسلح العمل المسلح هذا اضطراب لكن
بصوره عامه لعمل المسلح اثر وتوقفت الحياه
بشكل تام
وانتقلت النقاشات السياسيه ان تكون فقط
بينها وبين الجيش
وهذا امر يهمها جميعا في ان تمضي نحو حل
السلمي بالطبع الخيارات العسكريه هي الان
مطروح سنتحدث الان هناك عمليه عسكريه الان
يعني الامر لن ينتهي بعد لا نستطيع ان
نقول
على الجهه الاخرى هذا ليس خيارا الان
الحاكم لكن الخيار هو الاهداف التي من
دخلت الاطراف في العمليه السياسيه تتحققت
باي وسيله ليس هناك يعني داعم من الوصول
الى النصر الكاسح الذي يحقق دمار كبير في
البنيه التحتيه وكذلك
منه البلاد في اخر القوات المسلحه والدعم
السريع هما يعني اطراف في مؤسسه عسكريه
واحده ينبغي المحافظه عليهم وكذلك ينبغي
تطويرهم من اجل حمايه البلد والدستور ومن
ينبغي تعديل السلوك الذي
اقل من دقيقتين اريد ان اسمع من السيد من
السيد يتم هنالك من ربط بين الجلوس على
طاوله المحادثات وتلويح الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بفرض عقوبات على الجهات المسببه
لهذه المواجهات هل ترى ان هذا الربط منطقي
فعلا هناك شيء من المنطق في هذا اذا ان
ذلك يؤدي الى الضغوط لم يتعرض اي طرف
للعقوبات حسب علمي لحد الان ولكن حقيقه
التفكير بالعقوبات وعلى فرض ان كل العالم
يوافق عليها يعتبر عنصر الضغط ولكن النقطه
ينبغي التوضيحها ان اي من الجانبين لم
ينتصر ونوضح من في راي ان اي لن يستطيع
الحقيقه النصر العسكريا والنتيجه لابد ان
تكون العوده الى معده المفاوضات التي في
نهايه المطاف اولا تحلى مشكله او قلق
العسكري وهناك قلق اقتصادي هناك قلق حول
التعرف للعقوبه ومحاسبه لكثير من الجرائم
التي حصلت في سنوات الماضيه ثم بعد ذلك
مساله دمج القوات الدعم السريع والجيش
الجيش السوداني في جيش عسكريا واحد اخيرا
ثم الوصول الى الحكم المدني هذا هو
الاتجاه الذي ينبغي ان تسير عليه هذا
الموقف سيتمثل باختصار شديد في 30 ثانيه
كيف تطور الدوري الامريكي
الامريكي اساسا اخفق في اجبار الطرفين على
مناقشه
الخوف الرئيسيه في العسكريين التنقيب عن
الذهب من جانب
والحسبه والعقول المحاسبه وهذا كان جزء من
اتفاق الذي لم يحصل على نتائج
متفاوضيه هذا اثاره قلق العسكريين وهذا
الى
انقلاب اكتوبر 2021 والان هم هناك مازال
ذلك لو احتاج لحالك نستطيع ان نمضي قدما
الى الامام شكرا لك سيتم السفير الامريكي
السابقه في السودان كنت معنا من واشنطن
والشكر موصول للسيد حافظ كبير الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي والفريق اول فتح الرحمن
محي الدين قائد قوات البحريه السودانيه
السابقه الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]